so
like if i want to find somebody
really yeah and serious and someone i'm
gonna actually spend my life with
it would have to be somebody
more age-appropriate is scott disick
ready to start dating women his own age
if i love somebody
it doesn't matter their age
not sure about that
not quite i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day during the
series premiere of the kardashians the
38 year old reality star reflects on his
dating history during a chat with chloe
about his ex kourtney kardashian moving
on with travis barker now that
courtney's got her life with travis like
as hard as it is it does give me
a place to like finally be able to move
on so
like if i want to find somebody
really yeah and serious and someone i'm
going to actually spend my life with
it would have to be somebody
more age-appropriate yeah like
you know
21
when you're with an equal
yeah ever since court and scott split in
2015 he's been linked to a whole lot of
women in their early 20s like sofia
richie and lisa renna and harry hamlin's
daughter amelia gray hamlin now scott is
dating 27 year old model rebecca
donaldson who he actually brought to the
premiere of the new show scott and i
have been broken up for seven years and
i gave him 10 years before that so like
why is everyone making such a big deal
about this let's just not hate on a girl
who finally knows what she deserves back
in june 2021 scott gave court his
blessing to move on romantically during
the keeping up with the kardashians
reunion special i think if you really
love somebody right like you want them
to be happy no matter what
so i do give her a blessing to be happy
but things went south in august when
scott was publicly called out by
courtney's other ex eunice benjamin for
allegedly dming him some not so nice
comments about court's pda filled
vacation with travis that's not really
the vibe don't go damning my
ex-boyfriend yeah court addresses all
that in the series premiere too i woke
up to a text from scott saying
i'm so sorry i
dm'ed your ex-boyfriend who i can't
stand
he was asking if he could like apologize
for travis yeah that was nice
and then i wrote him this is dude tell
anyone
i said this is despicable and despite
all that the two continue to co-parent
the three children they share
twelve-year-old mason nine-year-old
penelope and seven-year-old reign i'm
really proud of all of them i think
they're doing amazing and i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
but scott admits it's been hard to watch
courtney move on it was a huge
adjustment losing courtney romantically
but now it's becoming a huge adjustment
losing her as kind of a best friend now
we're really just more of co-parenters
i would say it's probably one of the
more difficult things in my life
listen i at the end of the day i i
understand what the bigger picture is
what would be best for courtney and
she's happy how much do you all love
seeing courtney this happy oh we all
love it this is her time to shine baby
[Music]